ein auto rast in einem haus passiert ist
das in twistringen in niedersachsen im
kreis diepholz ist das direkt vom haus
ist das auto aus der kurve gerutscht
durch den vorgarten gekracht direkt in
das haus rein das schlimme dem
hausbewohner markus rank passiert das
nicht zum ersten mal mit ihm wollen wir
jetzt einmal sprechen schön dass sie bei
uns sind erlangt die kurve vor ihrem
haus die ist ja schon traurig berühmt
wie oft er ist da wenn jemand schon aus
der kurve geflogen bei ihnen
das kann ich gar nicht so genau sagen
ich mal sagen eigentlich unfall passiert
ihr fast jedes jahr mindestens ein also
das ist schon
fast gang und gäbe beschreiben sie noch
einmal wieder es dann heute nacht war
dort also das ist ja schon erheblicher
schaden der entstanden ist wie laut war
der knall wo waren sie gerade als das
passierte
ich lache in meinem bett direkt neben
kvasiny naja das auto ist an meinem
schlafzimmerfenster vorbeigeflogen das
hat gescheppert als wenn lkw ins haus
eingeschlagen ist
ja und dann bin ich raus und die
bescherung gesehen und dann sofort
geholfen also eigentlich ist das ja ein
riesiger ärger und trotzdem natürlich
hilft man dann erstmal was haben sie da
an der unfallstelle vorgefunden was
konnten sie da machen ja ich habe
erstmal die zwischen tür aufgemacht die
war ja nur da und dann hab ich ihnen
gerufen oder war der junge mann auch
schon ausgestiegen der stadt schon neben
seinem auto hat mir auch geantwortet
und dann habe ich erst mal halt notruf
abgesetzt hat bei der feuerwehr
angerufen und die habe ich dann halt
auch an die polizei weitergeleitet damit
dann auch die einsatzkräfte heute hier
vor ort kommen um das alles zu regeln es
stehen sie da heute morgen vor den
trümmern wie geht es denn jetzt weiter
für sie
jetzt für mich weiter gehen das ist
jetzt soweit komm mal die ganzen
versicherungstechnischen fragen gott sei
dank ist ja kein menschlicher schaden
entstanden ist es ja wirklich nur
sachschaden entstanden jetzt sind die
dort vereinbarte versicherungen und hier
wieder aufräumen weil zu weihnachten
möchte man es ja dann nachher auch
wieder ein bisschen schicken
frank ich bewundere ein bisschen wie
entspannt sie das alles erzähle müssen
das noch mal sagen da ist ein auto mit
voller wucht heute in ihr haus quasi an
ihr schlafzimmer an ihre an die wand
hinter ihrem bett geknallt sie erzählen
dass jetzt in entspanntheit aber sie
haben ja dauernd diesen ärger und das
wird er jetzt wahrscheinlich wochen wenn
nicht monate dauern bis das alles
aufgeräumt ist bis die schäden beseitigt
sind und so sie müsse eigentlich total
ärgerlich sein auf die die da immer in
ihre hauswand rein krachen ach wissen
sie es so ich wohne jetzt seit ungefähr
16 jahren in diesem haus und habe hier
jetzt schon so viel erlebt in diesem
haus und ich habe gelernt in meinem
leben wenn ich mich aufrege ändert das
an der situation nichts und man kann
immer froh sein wenn es ohne
personenschaden abgeht und weil so eine
hauswand oder mein auto wie gesagt das
ist ja nun auch beschädigt das kann man
ersetzen das sind alles sachen die die
tun nichts zur sache wichtig ist dass
keine person zu schaden gekommen ist
großartig und da kann man doch
eigentlich ganz glücklich sein das ist
noch relativ glimpflich abgegangen es
ist vermutlich genau die richtige
einstellung dennoch sie haben uns gesagt
mindestens einmal im jahr passiert so
etwas haben sie in den 16 jahren in
denen sie jetzt schon in ihrem häuschen
wurden mal gedacht nee also ganz ehrlich
leute ich sie woanders hin
wie soll ich das sagen also wie gesagt
ich von 16 jahre hier ich finde ich ja
eigentlich ganz wohl weil sie gesagt
wenn man 16 jahre irgendwo dann ist das
ja auch irgendwie ein zuhause und ich
bin ein mensch ich traue mich nicht so
gerne von meinem zuhause
und meine kinder sind hier aufgewachsen
und solche sachen und das wiegt das dann
doch so ein bisschen auf und was läuft
jetzt falsch letzte frage an sie heran
steht ihr haushalt einfach am falschen
ort oder ist die straße am falschen ort
nein sagen was man einfach so bringt sie
das haus und die straßen sind mit
falschen ort das problem ist dass das
haus direkt an einer kurve steht und du
hast vor der korb und nach tempo war
eine schöne lange gerade die verleitet
natürlich viele leute der zu glaskasten
auch durch zu treten und
dementsprechend dann wahrscheinlich auch
die kurve zu unterschätzen
und dann passieren halt solche
geschichten wie das hier und deswegen
ich habe oft genug erlebt und deswegen
rege ich mich da gar nicht mehr darüber
auf eine geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung oder
so etwas wollen sie da vielleicht noch
mal in der gemeinde darum bitten damit
ihr haus vielleicht im nächsten jahr
dann verschont bleibt oder haben sie
auch das schon aufgegeben aber so hat
soll ich ihnen sagen die
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung ist nicht
hier bei 70 aber es hält sich so gut wie
keiner dran
also es ist nicht das haus es ist nicht
die straße es sind eben die dort auf die
tube drücken das sagt herr vor seinem
zerstörten häuschen steht direkt hinter
seinem schlafzimmer dort heute nacht ein
auto rein gelassen heute ist es wurde
niemand dahinter in ras auch schon lkw
vorbei das gute ist es wurde niemand
verletzt dennoch in ganz ganz viel glück
durchhaltevermögen und bleiben sie bei
ihrer einstellung ich kann jetzt ewig
ändern ich lasse mir die laune nicht
verderben ja vielen dank herr rang genau
so ist es einfach das positive zu suchen
noch auszuziehen